bienvenidos a este espacio en el que en
france 24 hablamos de economía y para
eso estaba conmigo nuestra periodista
especializada daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida y empecemos hablando de la
fuga masiva de empresas en rusia hola
maria clara buenas noches pues 'la tras
la invasión de ucrania por parte de
rusia no solamente los gobiernos
occidentales han condenado a moscú
varias empresas han decidido limitar
suspender o abandonar sus actividades
comerciales en este país veamos la
naviera danesa maersk que tiene el 70 el
17 por ciento de la flota mundial de
contenedores suspenderá sus operaciones
en todos los puertos rusos aunque no
incluirá productos alimenticios ni
suministros médicos y humanitarios o
sean el networks y la suiza msc también
tomaron la misma decisión las petroleras
no se quedan atrás la british petroleum
saldrá de su participación en el gigante
ruso rosneft y la arrolló al dodge se le
seguirá también del país mientras que la
francesa total energy sse
pero no invertirá más dinero en esta
nación si hablamos de fabricantes de
automóviles mercedes benz volvo general
motors reno y jaguar land rover entre
otras decidieron suspender sus envíos o
frenar las operaciones en rusia daniela
pero la fuga no sólo se limita a estos
sectores donde masaje pues de fedex y
hubiese de eeuu dos de las empresas
logísticas más grandes del mundo no
harán envíos a asia a rusia ya ucrania y
los estudios de hollywood como disney
warner bros sony pictures y universal
pictures causarán los estrenos en cines
de sus próximas películas en
telecomunicaciones a por ericsson y
nokia suspendieron sus entregas como
respuesta al primer ministro ruso mijael
mesos sting anunció que se está
preparando un decreto que impone
restricciones temporales a la partida de
inversiones extranjeras aunque no dio
mayores detalles y está lista pues en sí
cree que sigue creciendo a medida que
pasan las horas y en este contexto
occidente declaró que quiere acabar la
economía rusa como pretende hacerlo pues
eeuu y europa están tratando de seguir
el mismo camino para ahogar la economía
rusa eeuu apunta a que sus sanciones
afecten al menos al 80 por ciento de
todos los activos bancarios rusos los
dos bancos más grandes de este país el
sberbank y el vtv ahora están aislados
del sistema financiero estadounidense al
igual que otras importantes
instituciones financieras y desde
occidente también se están restringiendo
severamente las exportaciones de
tecnología a rusia incluidos microchips
y piezas para sus industrias nuclear y
aeronáutica además del consejo de la
unión europea votó este martes a favor
de sanciones para excluir a algunos
bancos rusos del sistema swift como ya
lo hizo eeuu algunos líderes europeos
hablaron ante el tema al unísono
escuchados
wilson justo eficaz las sanciones están
teniendo impacto de hecho están teniendo
un impacto masivo y que no se equivoquen
sobre lo que europa está dispuesta a
hacer la determinación libraremos una
guerra económica y financiera total
'rusia llevaremos la economía rusa al
colateral
estamos preparados para hacer lo que sea
necesario para degradar la economía rusa
y detener la financiación de la
maquinaria de guerra de vladimir putin y
he sido muy clara en que habrá costos
para el público británico pero no son
como los costos que la gente de ucrania
está pagando en este momento por esta
terrible invasión y lo que está
sufriendo
daniela y por otro lado vemos que el
mercado del petróleo está intentando
reacomodarse en tiempos de guerra que
está pasando pues de maría clara miren
la ofensiva militar liderada por rusia
ha sembrado incertidumbre en el mercado
petrolero y provocó un alza de los
precios internacionales lo ha hecho
durante toda esta semana solamente hoy
tuvieron un aumento de alrededor del 10
por ciento de las referencias w de
imprenta en las más utilizadas en el
mundo esto porque rusia es el tercer
mayor productor mundial y el principal
exportador de crudo y eso pues puede
generar estas distorsiones en el mercado
pues de la agencia internacional de
energía que está conformada por 31
países acordó liberar unos 60 millones
de barriles estratégicas esto es el 4%
de los mil 500 millones de barriles que
tiene en total esto para garantizar que
no habrá problemas de suministro y para
estabilizar también los precios y como
esta crisis puede afectar a américa
latina pues la invitado primero que
escuchemos un análisis sobre el tema
claramente los precios del petróleo y
los precios de la gasolina suben debido
a la crisis eso va a generar grandes
problemas en términos de cadena de
suministro especialmente con la
interrupción de los puertos en el mar
negro y el impacto de las sanciones y el
resto de castigos que impondrán los
estadounidenses y los europeos
este mismo analista considera que aunque
algunos países productores de petróleo
como colombia méxico y venezuela se van
a beneficiar en el corto plazo de los
altos precios pues esta crisis también
tendrá un efecto dominó sobre las
economías de todo el mundo y es que una
de las consecuencias es que pueden subir
los precios de la electricidad también
de la gasolina del transporte y todo eso
se traduce en una mayor inflación de la
que ya tenemos maria clara a causa de la
pandemia a los últimos años pero
hablemos ahora de las personas como
están viviendo esta situación los
ucranianos y los rusos pues mire vámonos
para rusia primero en san petersburgo
que es la segunda ciudad más grande de
este país se ve gente observando con
desconsuelo las tablas de anuncios de
divisas que muestran cómo cae el rublo
frente a las principales monedas del
mundo de hecho esta moneda local rusa
cayó a un nuevo mínimo histórico este
mal escuchemos
y hay mucha gente que no entiende en qué
dirección está llevando a nuestro
gobierno la economía y todo en general
no habrá orden
todo era predecible porque las acciones
de putin son siempre las mismas esto es
el fascismo y el genocidio de ucrania y
sólo empeorará
y también lo haría claro se vieron
largas filas en el aeropuerto de
domodédovo que queda a cerca de moscú
donde pues varios turistas o incluso
ciudadanos rusos quedaron varados
después de que las naciones europeas
cerraran su espacio aéreo a los aviones
rusos ahora nos vamos para ucrania en
donde los residentes de la capital kiev
se enfrentan a largas colas para comprar
comida a la sombra de los edificios en
ruinas
creo que las preocupaciones de que las
tiendas de comestibles se queden sin
comunidad son muy relevantes no sabemos
qué nos pasará mañana hoy puedes entrar
libre y pacíficamente al supermercado
que está abastecido con ciertos
comestibles pero no sabemos si habrá una
manera de ingresar a que mañana si se
puede conseguir algo o no
daniela y ahora hablemos de los
indicadores pues a pensar a excepción
del mercado asiático las bolsas del
mundo cerraron el martes con grandes
pérdidas de más del 1 por ciento en el
caso de wall street en europa la pérdida
fue mayor pero quizás la consecuencia
para los mercados más palpables ahora
están los commodities el trigo se
disparó a su nivel más alto en 14 años
porque ucrania y rusia son grandes
exportadores el aceite de soya marco
máximo histórico y el país y el maíz
hizo lo propio pues juntos rusia y
ucrania representan una tercera parte de
las exportaciones mundiales de trigo una
quinta parte de las de maíz y el 80% de
las de aceite de girasol que compite con
el aceite de soya por eso es que los
precios están tanto madera daniela y
para terminar que cuál es la cifra del
día 1.700 millones de dólares esto busca
recolectar naciones unidas para
proporcionar asistencia humanitaria a
ucrania tras la invasión rusa la onu
estima que 12 millones de personas en
este país necesitarán protección
mientras que más de 4 millones de
refugiados ucranianos podrían requerir
ayuda en los países en los próximos
meses en los países vecinos bueno pues
esperaremos que la onu pueda recaudar
este dinero gracias daniela por toda
esta información y gracias a ustedes por
estar conectados con france24 esperen
más información aquí en nuestra señal
[Música]